what's up guys it's your boy phase code
tech and tutorials and i've got the
newest crypto scam for you just get me
to 10 million subs and i will scam you
hard just kidding
all right for real though we are going
to do some libraries
with cmake and visual studio community
edition this isn't something i've
covered yet so we're just going to walk
through it
let's just jump into it we'll make it as
quick as possible so i'm going to launch
visual studio first of all we're going
to make a new
project and when we make a new project
we are going to choose
cmake as the type you'll see this over
here if you don't see it you can search
for it
you should have it in your default setup
though so it should be here
and there you go give it a name we're
just going to call this
demo phase i gotta make fun of these
guys
how do you get to that many subs by
scamming people i don't get it get
together fellas get it together
i'm willing to bet that anyone
subscribed to my channel has not
subscribed to any of them
because we're in a whole different realm
of intellectuals
you have some stuff here you don't
really need to worry about this
configure stuff sure it gives you some
options
but it's just overview pages we're going
to do the overview here
look on the left side here or find your
solution explorer
so you have your out build here and you
have a
root level cmake which is this one right
here what this is going to do is add a
subdirectory of your project
which is over here and it gives us like
some root level stuff a dot h dot cpp
that dot cpp has some main and the dot h
is just for like your headers this is
kind of just a little starter project
nothing serious
and this cmake over here has your
executable
and the stuff to include to make your
executable pretty standard c make stuff
if you've seen the previous cmake videos
you'll know all this already
and it should apply what if you want to
start using libraries let's say for
example
we want to i don't know let's just pick
a library
let's just say glm it doesn't see glm
dot h but this could be in theory any
library you pick your library whatever
library you need
you'll see that you can't include it so
what you have to do
is a couple different things uh first of
all let's just
launch our terminal and let's find the
library we want with dc package manager
if you don't know how to do this vc
package manager stuff i do have a video
on that too
that gets you all going i'll reference
that
somewhere in case you don't know but if
you're good you're good
so uh we're going to install pick a
library
let's say we want to do vulcan and i've
already got installed with 64
and all that so we're we're good here
but if we tried to
include vulcan for example
we're not seeing it which is not seeing
it and to fix that
well you will see i want to type
integrate install in here
and to great install just to see the
command and it'll tell you a cmake
project should use and there's this
tool chain it's going to be different
for you as you can see it's a file that
says esource
so this is my local drive yours will be
different
and you just want to copy this and then
you want to go
back to visual studio up here where it
says your debug thing and go to manage
configurations
and under manage configurations you pick
the config you're going to build with
we're going to stick with x64 debug just
because it's default
you will find in here the cmake tool
chain file
so you can path to it by clicking this
little button here but if you've already
copied it you just paste it right in
there
just the path to that vc and just save
this
control s or whatever what you have to
do next is you want to go to your cmake
list the one for the project
and you want to add it let's do
so when you install it tells you how to
use it
now this says since it's already
installed doesn't tell you how to use it
but we can get a little example by just
googling real quick here you will see
that it just talks about some stuff that
we kind of already know
or should if you don't even read through
it basically when you install a library
to use it in your cmake other than what
we just previously did you also have to
put this fine package
and target link libraries into your code
and it shows you some more examples
somewhere down here
[Music]
we're not worried about this but here's
an example cmake see they have the fine
package
and the target link uh so let's just add
those
so let's copy that code there and put it
right here
and put it up here vulcan
falcon config required target link
libraries
are some called main it's called demo
face paste that in there they had one
too many brackets
and it looks like it doesn't see i
believe we gotta go bulk in vulcan
and doesn't quite see it let me figure
out what i'm doing wrong after doing a
little research
uh i found a few little tricks so
if you want to add one of these
libraries of course you gotta tell to
find it after you've installed
vc pkg usually config and usually
required
and then you want to link it and we're
just going to give a little bit glm
uh so glm would be like so and then we
can go to our header
and intellisense should start picking it
up so we can start
doing glm stuff and using glm code
aglm x3 for example just that's
something to test here and we'll slide
it
as you can see it's happy with it seems
to like it and we could run our code
and uh it compiles so
if we want to do that with other ones
say we want to add i don't know if you
want to get like the opengl stuff for
we would add glad to this we would also
add
glad glad now most of them are like this
but not all of them so that's an
important distinction not all
libraries are created equally so there
we could get
our glad stuff going and if we want to
get glf w
i'm using these just because i've done a
lot of tutorials that involve them
glf w3 is a little different let's see
if you try to do
what you expect here gel w3 gel w3
it's uh it's not too happy uh i could
probably
dig it up and research i couldn't figure
out exactly what it wants here
but what you can do is if you don't want
to keep guessing you can just
uh use the macro that is gfw
libraries and that seems to
link the right thing and of course you
can do that for these other ones too
uh just some kind of little handy trick
here
i'll show glad you should be able to do
this with in general all of them now
seem to be happy
you can also include glfw here and then
we should be able to start like uh we
could you know we could
use some code from one of my previous
examples or from my
gel tutorial and make a window and all
that with this setup so this could get
you going pretty quick
with uh with any library
i was looking at vulcan and vulcan is
definitely a little
different here was able to exactly
figure it out for example if i do find
package
balkan config uh we'll get rid of this
one for now
comment it out it's not happy with just
find packet bulk and
fig because it's a modulus so if we get
rid of config
then it picks it up as a module it's now
happy but now the link libraries
is a little different i tried the
obvious
vulcan it's not happy with that i tried
some other things i tried
sdk i tried underscore sdk
so yeah you can just use the macro and
that one seems to be happy
however when we go back over to here and
try to include it
it's not picking it up and that's where
i kind of got stuck so we do have here
on
the lunar g website some info about it
this is a slightly older version these
should be the same
it says you put in here find package
vulcan required we seem to have that
right
and it does also say that you want to
specify
your platform with target compile
definitions so
maybe that's what we need and the target
link libraries looks like you just put
vulcan with capital v
yeah that appears to be it just needs to
be capitalized so all the libraries are
a little different some of them want a
capital letter it doesn't need to be
exact
you can always use this macro if you
can't quite figure it out so that
is one thing that is kind of nice
however we're still running into one
problem of not being able to
include vulcan here it's just
intellisense isn't seeing it thanks to
the power of the internet we have found
some additional
information here on one of the bcp kg
issues on github and someone just
reporting the same problem saying hey i
can't find header
and the answer seems to be and we're
going to try this out make sure it works
is the vulcan port does not actually
copy the falcon headers over all it does
is verify they exist
under the vulcan sdk you are responsible
for actually adding the include path so
let's add that include path
there are several ways of doing this we
could of course copy
then clues over into our project as like
an include folder so like we would go
something like add folder
include and then maybe make a vulcan in
here and drag them over
but it looks like you do actually need
to go get the sdk
or find it somewhere because falcon
as you might know comes with your video
card drivers
so let's dig into that real quick here
so i do have the vulcan sdk
on one of my drives and here it is
and you'll see include and we've got
some code here including vulcan so we
could take this
and literally target include libraries
to that path so that's what we're going
to try here
something like that now it goes to show
that
these problems they might seem
significant but they're often really
minor
literally the problem was the wrong
slashes copied over
so you would either have to use double
slashes or just switch it to these ones
now if you update your sdk you gotta
update this include
there might be a better way of doing
this if you know a better way of making
this more automatic
feel free to leave a comment but now
once you do that you should be able to
put bulk in and start using
falcon dot whatever you need now i don't
want to make this a vulcan tutorial but
basically
you should be able to start uh
implementing your folk
code for whatever you're doing now
that's just another example i just kind
of wanted to cover
somewhat of a broad scope of libraries
here
just to give you as many ideas as
possible
we're just gonna do build make sure it
builds here but yeah that's
that's it there's some examples of how
to get cmake
and your library working on visual
studio community edition
hope you enjoyed this episode seeing the
next one
[Music]
you